This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证真人。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2（TWO）。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我要成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就此逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
他会得到应有的惩罚。我们常说，要相信你的女性朋友们。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回望过去》（The Look Back at it）播客中。对1979年来说，那对我是个大日子。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难学步》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人带着一身铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学步》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces
2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了
consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode of the psychology of your 20s. We have a lot to discuss today, a lot to learn, a lot of opinions to break down and to maybe confirm, maybe not. I'm really excited for it because I think that the dilemma we are discussing today is a pretty common dilemma. I think nearly every single one
后果。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十岁时经历的一些重大生活改变和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到本播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听又一期的《你二十岁的心理学》。我们今天有很多要讨论的，有很多要学习的，有很多观点需要剖析，也许去证实，也许去证伪。我对此真的非常兴奋，因为我认为我们今天讨论的困境是一个相当普遍的困境。我想几乎我们当中的每一个人
of us comes across it at some point in our lives, especially in our 20s and what we are talking about today is disliking someone that one of your friends is dating. Okay, so let me paint a picture for you. Your friend has been single for a couple of years. You know, that's been really hard for her. She really is a lover girlie. She is someone who loves being monogamous. She likes creating a bit of a nest and a home with a partner. And that just kind of hasn't really been part of her story recently. She's just really struggled to find someone. She's been on all the apps, putting yourself out there. And then one day she meets someone. And they've been dating for a a month and you finally get to meet him and you hate him. He is not your kind of guy. He's dismissive,
在人生的某个阶段都会遇到它，尤其是在我们二十岁的时候。而我们今天要讨论的是：讨厌你的某个朋友正在约会的人。好吧，让我为你描绘一幅画面。你的朋友已经单身好几年了。你知道，这对他/她来说真的很不容易。他/她真的是个恋爱脑。他/她是一个热爱一夫一妻制的人。他/她喜欢和伴侣一起营造一点小巢和一个家。而这在最近似乎并不是他/她故事的一部分。他/她只是很难找到某个人。他/她用过所有的交友软件，积极展现自己。然后有一天，他/她遇到了某个人。他们已经约会了一个月，你终于见到了他，而你讨厌他。他不是你喜欢的那种人。他很冷漠、
he's arrogant and your friend just cannot seem to see what is going on. She is like gushing. She is super in love and suddenly he is turning up everywhere as is expected when one of your friends is in love with someone. You know, you go to the movies together. He's there. He's at every girls night, every group outing, and the more opportunities you have to spend time with him, the more you actually grow to dislike him. So this is the dilemma. Do you say anything? Or you kind of bound into silence by the invisible pact we all have with our friends. You don't have to like everything that they do, but you do have to be supportive. I think that this experience is one that all of us can relate to. We can't be friends with everybody in the world. They're not all going to be our
他很傲慢，而你的朋友似乎根本看不清发生了什么。他/她一直在狂热夸赞。他/她超级恋爱脑，突然之间他开始到处出现，就像你的某个朋友陷入热恋时所预料的那样。你知道，你们一起去看电影。他在。他在每一个女孩之夜、每一次集体出游中，而你有越多机会和他相处，你实际上就越发讨厌他。所以这就是困境。你要说出来吗？还是说，我们与朋友之间隐形的契约将你束缚得只能沉默？你不需要喜欢他们做的一切，但你必须给予支持。我认为这种经历是我们所有人都能感同身受的。我们不可能和世界上的每个人都做朋友。他们不会全都是我们的
cup of tea. And unfortunately, one of those people we don't get along with may be destined to end up with someone that we do love and we love a lot as their partner. I think this is especially common and perhaps felt more profoundly in our 20s for two reasons. Firstly, this is really a period of exploration and romantic discovery for a lot of us, right? You know, we are exploring what we like, our type, the kind of people we see a future with. And there might be a few duds in there. There's probably going to be a few duds, actually. That is a big part of dating in our 20s, being open to different people, even if they are not always the one per se. So just as you may have dated people, your friends despised of, trust me, I have been there, I have done that. Your friends
茶。而不幸的是，我们合不来的这些人中，可能注定会和我们所爱的人——作为伴侣被我们深深喜爱的人——走到一起。我认为这在二十岁时尤为常见，并且感受可能更深刻，原因有二。首先，对我们中的许多人来说，这确实是一个探索和浪漫发现的时期，对吧？你知道，我们在探索我们喜欢什么、我们的类型、我们认为能与之共度未来的人。而这其中可能会有几个不合适的人。实际上，可能还会有不少不合适的人。这是我们二十岁约会很大的一部分，对不同的人保持开放态度，即使他们不总是那种完美的人。因此，正如你可能和你的朋友们极其鄙视的人约过会一样——相信我，我经历过，我做过——你的朋友
are also going through the same kind of romantic developmental chapter, and they're going to bring people into their life and by association your life that you're just not going to like. Additionally, when we're talking about this decade of emerging adulthood, as psychologists would call it, our most important relationships are our friends and our partners compared to in our childhood in teenage years when our parents and our families really, we're not. played a bigger role. As we kind of leave the orbit of the family home, as we're kind of seeking independence, our friends become our support network. They're our confidence. They are the people that we probably spend the most time with. So sometimes these relationships can come into
也正在经历同样的情感发展阶段，他们会把一些人带入他们的生活，进而通过这种关联带入你的生活，而你是绝对不会喜欢这些人的。此外，当我们谈论心理学家所说的成年早期这十年时，我们最重要的关系是我们的朋友和伴侣，这与我们的童年和青少年时期不同，那时我们的父母和家庭并没有扮演那么重要的角色。当我们离开家庭的轨道，当我们寻求独立时，我们的朋友成为了我们的支持网络。他们是我们的知己。他们可能是我们花最多时间相处的人。所以有时这些关系会产生
conflict, right? The relationship between your friends and your partner, especially if you're super close friends and you're finding that this new boyfriend or girlfriend or person is really getting in the way of a pre-established and very deep bond. You can't help but dislike the disruption of the norm and this new person because they have changed the nature of your friendship, you know, or it's just jealousy, maybe it's personality differences, maybe it's because there are really serious red flags that you know your friend cannot see. What do you do in those circumstances? Is it about keeping the peace versus speaking your mind? Do you have a right to get your point across?
冲突，对吧？你的朋友和伴侣之间的关系，特别是如果你和朋友超级亲密，而你发现这个新男友、女朋友或某个人真的妨碍了你们先前建立且非常深厚的联系。你情不自禁地会讨厌这种对常态的破坏，讨厌这个新人，因为他们改变了你们友谊的性质，你知道的，或者这只是嫉妒，也许是性格差异，也许是因为真的存在你明知你的朋友看不到的严重危险信号。在这种情况下你该怎么办？这是关于维持和平还是说出你的真实想法？你是否有权表明自己的观点？
Or is it just one of those instances where you just have to stay silent? And you just kind of have to handle this with grace. Spoiler alert, it's very nuanced, but I would say the majority of the time, I think it's only right to bat your tongue with a few exceptions that we're going to discuss. That's what we're going to be talking about because I know this feeling. I have been both friends in this situation, right? I've been the friend who's been dating somebody that all of my friends said they hated and disliked and I didn't want to listen. And I've also been the person who's seen my friends in relationships like that and been like,
还是说这只是那种你必须保持沉默的情况？你只能靠优雅来度过这一切。剧透一下，情况非常微妙，但我可以说，大多数时候，我觉得除了我们即将讨论的少数例外情况外，管住自己的嘴才是正确的。这就是我们要讨论的内容，因为我懂这种感觉。在这种情况下，两种朋友我都当过，对吧？我当过那种正在和所有人都不喜欢、都讨厌、而我偏偏不想听劝的人约会的朋友；我也当过那种看着朋友处于这种恋爱关系中，心想：
what are they thinking they need to leave? And there is actually quite a lot of psychology to pull from to describe some of this frustration, resentment, even sadness that we feel during these times. So let us get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange, modern world.
他们在想什么啊，他们需要分手的人。实际上，有很多心理学知识可以用来解释我们在这些时期感受到的一些沮丧、怨恨甚至是悲伤。让我们深入探讨一下吧。《2%》。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇异的现代世界中，关于心理韧性、健身以及培养抗压能力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that doesn't. dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看穿那些在健康产业中占据主导地位的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
收听《2%》。名字是字母拼写的 T-W-O-Percent，在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回望过去》播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84's big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day but just so y'all know I mean at this point
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格ish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时准备在任何一天聊聊快克，但只是为了让你们知道，我的意思是，在这一点上
Mark this is the second episode where we've discussed crack so I'm starting to see that there's a through line We also have AIDS on the table right now So Thank you finishing that sentence I don't think there's a more important year For black people
马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集，所以我开始发现这里有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。所以谢谢你完成了那句话。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了
Really? Yeah for me it's one of the most important years For black people in American history Listen to look back at it On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games.
真的吗？是的，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回望过去》。欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学步》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。
And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是：特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们都在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要吗？你做个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你纯粹只是因为想做一个好人。
Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app, Search learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《艰难学步》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio App，搜索《艰难学步》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
这开启了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。埃伦斯女士，你曾两次伪造这份特定的测试，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两名经历过同样事情的男性。
Gregalespian and Michael Maranini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice.
格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《深陷爱河》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。
served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。任何男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。法则一，绝对不要招惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也绝对不要招惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，要相信你的女性朋友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield. And in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德。在这个新一季的《闺蜜们》中，天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了一样。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意。所以她们决定自己采取行动。
I said, oh, hell no. I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think it's best to firstly identify why you don't like your friend's partner.
我说，哦，见鬼不。我发誓。我要成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。听听闺蜜们怎么说。相信我，宝贝。在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我认为首先最好弄清楚你为什么不喜欢你朋友的伴侣。
And how I see it is that we often don't like them for one of three reasons. Firstly, you don't like them personally because they just aren't your type of person, but they are your friends type of person. There is some personality or preference clash going on. Secondly, you don't like them because this new relationship has changed the nature of your friendship, meaning that your friend is perhaps less accessible, less available, they're canceling plans to be with their partner. And this kind of leads to a resentment that is projected onto this new person when really it's just coming from a place of adjustment and what I like to call
我是这样看的：我们不喜欢他们通常出于以下三个原因之一。首先，你在个人层面上不喜欢他们，因为他们根本不是你喜欢的那种人，但他们却是你朋友喜欢的那种人。这里存在着某种性格或偏好的冲突。其次，你不喜欢他们是因为这段新恋情改变了你们友谊的性质，这意味着你的朋友可能变得不那么容易接近、不那么有空了，他们为了和伴侣在一起而取消计划。这导致了一种怨恨，并将这种怨恨投射到了这个新人身上，而实际上它只是源于适应阶段以及我称之为
growing pains. And finally, you don't like your friend's partner because of how they treat your friend. You are beginning to notice some behaviours that are major red flags, whether that be control tactics, manipulation, anger, sometimes even abuse, weaponised incompetence. There's a long list of things that we're going to get to. And I think that that final class of reasons is probably the only exception to the don't say anything rule, right? When you know that this is like kind of a question of safety, I do think you have a right to speak up. And we're going to talk about that in a second. These three reasons obviously differ greatly in severity, right? Like one is a matter of liking. One is a matter of insecurity. And the final one is really a matter of, like we said, safety. So we're
成长阵痛的东西。最后，你不喜欢你朋友的伴侣是因为他们对待你朋友的方式。你开始注意到一些属于重大危险信号的行为，无论是控制 tactics（策略）、操纵、愤怒，有时甚至是虐待、武器化无能。我们要讨论的事情有一长串。我认为最后这类原因可能是“什么都别说”这条规则唯一的例外，对吧？当你知道这有点像是一个安全问题时，我确实认为你有权大声说出来。我们一会儿就会讨论这个。这三个原因在严重程度上显然有很大差异，对吧？比如，一个是喜好的问题。一个是缺乏安全感的问题。而最后真正关乎的正如我们所说，是安全问题。所以我们
going to talk about these three reasons separately. I think they deserve a different kind of response. Of course, starting with, I would say the first situation, which is definitely the moment. majority of instances in which we don't like our friend's partner. And it really comes down to the fact that our preferences clash. And the person that they chose is not the person that we would have chosen for them based on our preferences. There is just something about them that sticks out that we can't look past. Maybe they're arrogant, they're boring, they're lazy, they're rude, they have a job that we don't agree with. and as a result, we kind of get a secondhand ick. It's really so interesting to me when this happens,
将分别讨论这三个原因。我认为它们值得不同类型的回应。当然，首先要从我所说的第一种情况开始，这绝对占了我们不喜欢朋友伴侣的大多数情况。它真的归结于这样一个事实：我们的偏好发生冲突。他们选择的人不是基于我们的偏好，我们会为他们选择的人。他们身上就是有某种突出的特质，让我们无法忽视。也许他们傲慢、无聊、懒惰、粗鲁、有着我们不认同的工作，
because how is it that we can get along so well with someone, that being our friend, and not their partner? Because it's kind of like two limbs or branches, like sticking out of the same tree, right? Like, you would think that they would be alike, but no, that is obviously not always the case. And a lot of this does come down to things that we independently decide for ourselves. like our non-negotiables, like our deal breakers, like our preferences that our friends are just not always going to share. Let's talk about the psychology of this for a little while. So each of us has a unique profile of what we find attractive in someone or what we would call mating preferences in psychology. So there is mating preferences. I know it sounds like super reductive. These preferences
结果呢，我们产生了一种代入式的厌恶。当这种情况发生时，我真的觉得非常有趣，因为为什么我们能和某个人——也就是我们的朋友——相处得那么好，却无法和他们的伴侣相处呢？因为这有点像从同一棵树上伸出来的两根枝条或树枝，对吧？你会觉得他们应该相似，但事实显然并非总是如此。这很大程度上确实归结于我们独立为自己做出的决定，比如我们的不妥协底线、我们的交易破裂点、我们的偏好，而我们的朋友并不总是会和我们共享这些。让我们花点时间谈谈这背后的心理学。因此，我们每个人都有一个独特的心理画像，关于我们在某人身上觉得有吸引力的特质，或者在心理学中我们称之为择偶偏好。所以存在择偶偏好。我知道这听起来超级还原主义。这些偏好
they derive from a number of factors such as genetics, genetic in printing, which essentially says that we seek out partners who resemble our parents, really strange. Things like pheromones and their influence on sexual attraction, attachment style, self-perception, self-esteem, what feels familiar and safe to us. There is a whole number of studies that looks at what it is that creates this unique profile. That last factor is especially the target of a lot of academic consideration. We are attracted to people who feel like they complement us or they're similar to ourselves based on things like values, education level, socioeconomic status, how we were raised, even race.
源于许多因素，如基因、基因印记（它本质上表明我们寻找长得像父母的伴侣，真的很奇怪）、诸如信息素及其对性吸引力的影响、依恋风格、自我认知、自尊、对我们来说熟悉和安全的感觉。有大量研究探讨了究竟是什么创造了这种独特的心理画像。最后一个因素尤其成为许多学术考量的重要目标。我们被那些让我们觉得能与我们互补、或者根据价值观、教育水平、社会经济地位、成长背景甚至种族等因素与我们相似的人所吸引。
This may explain why we often see people date in their own league. And I know that is a really weird and reductionist phrase and a weird thing to say, but it kind of turns out to be true. It's not always about physical attraction. It's more about dating people who are aligned with you. We are more attracted to people who are like us in some domain. And we're seeing more research say that if someone meets our core requirements, we may tend to overlook or justify other things about them that may not be 100% what we want.
这或许可以解释为什么我们经常看到人们在同阶层中约会。我知道这是一个非常奇怪且还原主义的短语，也是一句奇怪的话，但它最终往往是真的。这并不总是关于身体吸引力。这更多是关于与那些与你同频的人约会。我们更容易被在某些领域与我们相似的人吸引。并且我们看到越来越多的研究表明，如果有人满足了我们的核心要求，我们往往会忽视或原谅他们身上其他可能并非100%符合我们心意的地方。
There is, of course, also the theory that opposites attract. There's obviously some, I would say some evidence for that, that, you know, we choose people based on our own weaknesses, based on their strengths that kind of counteract our weaknesses, better to say it like that. So if we are insecure, we seek out a partner who is confident. If, I don't know, we like the color yellow, we seek out a partner who likes the color blue and then we have the full spectrum. You know, I don't fully think that that is true. that is a much more psychoanalytic theory and has less evidence. But I think nonetheless, we've kind of been sidelined, everything kind of combines to create
当然，也有“异性相吸”的理论。显然有一些证据支持这一点，即我们选择伴侣是基于我们自己的弱点，基于他们能够抵消我们弱点的优势——这样说更贴切。因此，如果我们缺乏安全感，我们就会寻找一个自信的伴侣。如果，我不知道，我们喜欢黄色，我们就会寻找一个喜欢蓝色的伴侣，然后我们就拥有了完整的色彩光谱。你知道，我并不完全认为那是真的。那是一个更加精神分析的理论，受到的证据支持较少。但尽管如此，我认为我们或多或少都被边缘化了，各种因素结合在一起创造了
this profile, right? What we find familiar creates a profile. What we find attractive based on our past creates this profile. Our education level creates this profile. Our attachment creates this profile. And this is going to be different for all of us. None of us are going to be the same. none of us are going to have the exact same background, the exact same upbringing, genetics, emotional
这个画像，对吧？我们觉得熟悉的事物创造了一个画像。基于我们过去觉得有吸引力的事物创造了这个画像。我们的教育水平创造了这个画像。我们的依恋风格创造了这个画像。这对我们每个人来说都是不同的。没有两个人是完全相同的，没有两个人会拥有完全相同的背景、完全相同的成长经历、基因、情感
and relationship history. Even like if you think about like your siblings, even people who are siblings end up dating people who are so different. So their standards are going to differ between you and your friend. And it's frustrating, but you kind of just have to be there to watch that and be there to accept that what you might look for in someone, they're not looking for as well. I think the reason this can be so uncomfortable is because you really want what's best for them. This is someone you adore and cherish. You obviously think is incredible. Very few people can meet the standard that you've set for your friend in your own mind. And we want to protect them from pain, right?
以及恋爱历史。甚至就像如果你想想你的兄弟姐妹，即使是亲兄弟姐妹最终约会的人也截然不同。因此，你和朋友之间的标准会有所不同。这很令人沮丧，但你只能去看着它并接受这样一个事实：你在某人身上寻找的东西，他们可能并不在寻找。我认为这种情况之所以会让人感到如此不舒服，是因为你真的希望他们能得到最好的。这是你宠爱和珍视的人。你显然觉得他们不可思议。极少数人能达到你在自己心中为朋友设定的标准。我们想要保护他们免受伤害，对吧？
It's very easy in those circumstances to think, you know, I know what is best. I know how to protect my friend. I know that this relationship isn't going to work. they need to just listen to me and they would avoid so much pain. I get it. You want to be their eyes whilst love is kind of blinding them in a way and whilst they're getting carried away in the honeymoon stage, you want to be their guide and you might be sitting there thinking,
在那种情况下，很容易让人觉得：“我知道什么才是最好的。我知道如何保护我的朋友。我知道这段感情不会成功。他们只需要听我的，就能避免那么多的痛苦。”我懂。你想成为他们的眼睛，而爱情在某种程度上让他们盲目，当他们沉浸在蜜月期时，你想成为他们的指引。你可能会坐在那里想：
you know, I need to do something about this as a friend. I'm going to pause you right there. It's important to remember that this person who they are dating, who you don't like, may be part of their journey. which as shitty as it is, just because you see the potential mistake, doesn't mean that you can do the work for your friend. They let you make your mistakes, I'm sure of it, and now it's your time to repay the favor.
“作为一个朋友，我需要对此做点什么。”我得在这里按一下暂停键。重要的是要记住，这个他们正在约会而你又不喜欢的人，可能是他们人生旅程的一部分。尽管这很糟糕，但仅仅因为你看到了潜在的错误，并不意味着你可以替你的朋友去做功课。他们让你犯过错误，我对此深信不疑，现在轮到你投桃报李了。
You don't know what this person will be for them in their journey, right? You don't know what kind of decisions they'll make for this person or to stay with this person that actually might end up creating a life after this person that's amazing. You don't know what this person is leading them to, what they need to experience through this relationship. All you see is someone you love and you want to kind of cushion the full and make their life easier. And sometimes in those circumstances, I think you just have to bite your tongue. This is one of those examples. If they make your friend happy, if they are respectful and kind, that is an equally crucial factor,
你不知道这个人对他们的旅程意味着什么，对吧？你不知道他们会为了这个人做出什么样的决定，或者为了和这个人在一起而最终创造出一段超越这个人的精彩人生。你不知道这个人会把他们引向何方，他们在通过这段关系经历什么时是必须要经历的。你看到的只是一个你爱的人，你想减轻他们的跌倒，让他们的生活更轻松。有时在这种情况下，我认为你只能咬紧牙关。这就是其中一个例子。如果这个人让你的朋友感到快乐，如果他们尊重且善良，那同样是一个至关重要的因素，
maybe that's all we can ask for. and your dislike should not be a factor. I think, in fact, it can be rather hurtful if expressed. You know, I had a friend once say to me that an ex-partner of mine was boring and annoying. And you know what I interpreted that as, whether this is correct or incorrect, I interpreted this at the time as my friend saying, you know, it's not that I don't like your partner, it's that I don't think that your preferences are good enough. I saw it as like a judgment of my standards
也许这就是我们所能要求的全部了。而你的不喜欢不应该成为一个影响因素。事实上，如果表达出来，可能会相当伤人。你知道，我曾有个朋友对我说，我的前伴侣又无聊又烦人。你知道我是怎么解读这番话的吗？无论这种解读是否正确，我当时把这解读为我的朋友在说：“你知道，不是我讨厌你的伴侣，而是我认为你的标准不够高。”我把它看作是对我标准的一种批判，
and that they were so low that I was willing to be with this person because I was settling essentially and so it turned from being a criticism of this guy of my ex to being a criticism of me and it made me in my mind at least and it made me question the relationship but also the friendship at the same time was I a bad judge of character? Is this what this person thought? What else did this friend think of me? Should I just
而且我的标准太低了，以至于我愿意和这个人在一起，因为我基本上是在将就。所以这从小伙子、从我前任身上的一场批判，变成了一场对我的批判，这让我在心里——至少在我的脑海里——不仅开始质疑这段感情，同时也开始质疑这段友谊：难道我是一个糟糕的看人眼光者吗？这个人就是这么想我的吗？这个朋友还对我有别的什么看法吗？我是不是应该
break up with this guy because eventually I would see what my friends saw and there would be this endless round of I told you so's. I think when you criticize a person's partner out of personal dislike, you are not helping them and you are at risk of creating resentment, especially since we are seeing more research coming out of social psychology that our friends' opinions on our dating lives do impact our decision making. So there was this study published a few years ago out of Indiana University and what they found was that when people knew that their friends did not like their partner, this greatly influenced the actual length of the relationship. Now that could be for two reasons. Either our friends impacted our decision and so we called it quits when we shouldn't have
甩了这个家伙，因为最终我会看到朋友们所看到的东西，然后就会迎来无休止的“我早就告诉你了”。我认为，当你出于个人好恶去批判朋友的伴侣时，你并没有在帮他们，而且你有引发怨恨的风险，特别是正如我们从社会心理学中看到的越来越多的研究所表明的那样，朋友对我们约会生活的看法确实会影响我们的决策。几年前印第安纳大学发表过这样一项研究，他们发现，当人们知道自己的朋友不喜欢他们的伴侣时，这极大地影响了恋情实际持续的长短。这可能有两方面的原因。要么是我们的朋友影响了我们的决定，所以我们在不该分手的时候分了手，
or maybe our friend recognized something before we did. The relationship was doomed to fail. We just were in, you know, the friend just saw it before we had the opportunity too. I just think regardless, don't put up the war between yourself and this person that you care about from a place of judgment. An even larger consequence, I think, of you expressing your opinion and your friends disagreeing is that they will no longer want to talk to you about what's going on in their relationship. So if something seriously was to go wrong, they feel too ashamed or embarrassed or isolated
或者也许我们的朋友比我们更早发现了某些端倪。这段关系注定是要失败的。我们只是身处其中（而朋友比我们更早有机会看到真相）。我只是觉得无论如何，不要出于评判的心理，在你自己和这个你关心的人之间筑起一堵墙。我认为，你表达意见而朋友不赞同带来的更大后果是，他们将不再想跟你谈论他们感情中正在发生的事情。因此，如果真的出了什么严重的问题，他们会感到太羞耻、太尴尬或太孤立而不敢告诉你任何事，因为他们不想面对这种尴尬，他们不想面对你说“哦，我早就知道了”。这绝对是你能有的最糟糕的感觉。我认为在这种情况下最好的做法是什么都不说，真的只能咬紧牙关，确保你的朋友仍然觉得可以依靠你来倾诉，他们可以依靠你来发泄，他们可以向你征求建议，并且他们能够在需要帮助时来到你身边，
to tell you anything because they don't want to deal with the impassee. embarrassment, they don't want to deal with you being like, oh, I knew all along. That's like the worst feeling that you can have. I think what's best in this situation is to really say nothing, really kind of just have to bite your tongue, make sure that your friend is still, still feels like they can rely on you to talk about it, they can rely on you to rant about it, they can ask for your advice and they can kind of come to you in times of need. without the risk that your opinion on their partner is going to influence them or maybe hurt your friendship. I know it's really difficult because you obviously care, but there is definitely a level
而不用冒着你对他们伴侣的看法会影响他们、或者可能伤害你们友谊的风险。我知道这真的很困难，因为你显然很关心他们，但这绝对需要达到一定程度的敏感度。所以我们来谈谈这第二个原因。你可能不喜欢你朋友的伴侣，是因为你或许在嫉妒。我知道我们不喜欢承认这一点。嫉妒在我们脑海里是个不好的词，被人说嫉妒可不是什么好滋味。这不是我们喜欢听到的。嫉妒也不是我们很可能会供认不讳的东西。但有时我们就是无法控制那种感觉。它就像任何其他情绪一样。有时它感觉像是来自一个我们无法控制的地方。而且这不一定是因为性方面的嫉妒。你并不是被他们的朋友所吸引。你并不是被他们的伴侣所吸引。这更多是一种社交圈子里的嫉妒，你觉得原本稳固的友谊和纽带被这段新恋情给拆散了，
of sensitivity required. So let's talk about this second reason. You may not like your friend's partner because you are perhaps jealous. I know we don't like to admit it. Jealousy is an ugly word in our brains to be called jealous. It's not something that we like to hear. And jealousy is also not something that we're likely going to fess up to. But sometimes we just can't help that feeling. It's like any other emotion. It sometimes feels like it's coming from a place that we don't have control over. And it's not necessarily sexual jealousy. You are not attracted to their friend. You are not attracted to their partner. It's more a form of platonic jealousy, whereby you feel like this previously solid friendship and bond has been dismantled by this new
突然之间，你的朋友有了一套新的优先事项，而你在他/她心目中的排序不再像他们的伴侣那么高了。我真的很理解这一点。我真的懂。当你和朋友们一起单身，或者你们都在经历相同的事情，或者拥有那种亲密感、你们永远是彼此心中的首位时，总是要有趣得多。当这一切因为一个新男友、新女朋友而被从我们身边夺走时，我们本能地——我可以说这是一种自然反射——会想要去保护我们所珍视的东西，无论是物质财产还是某种关系。因为天生，我们多少都是有些贪婪的生物，对吧？我们希望把人全占为己有。我知道这听起来有点难听。我认为这是一种让我们感到非常羞耻的事情，但这某种程度上就是事实，对吧？人类想要更多。我们总是想要更多。我们总是想要对我们最有利的东西。我们总是想要更多的爱、更多的财富、更多的affection（情感），
relationship whereby suddenly your friend has a new set of priorities and you are not as high on the list as their partner is. I really get this. I really do. It's always so much more fun when you and your friends are all single together or you're all experiencing the same things or there is that closeness, you're always the top of each other's list. And when that gets taken away from us, because of a new boyfriend, a new girlfriend, we feel very instinctively, it's a natural reflex, I would say, to feel protective over the things that we value, whether that is a material possession or a relationship. Because innately, we are kind of greedy creatures, right? And we want people all to ourselves. I know that's kind of an ugly thing to say. That's something that I think we feel
有时我认为，看到我们所珍视的东西——比如朋友的关爱、朋友的同情心以及朋友的陪伴——被所谓的夺走，会导致我们产生非常强的防御心理。不幸的是，我认为这不是我们能控制的事情，也不是我们可以宣之于口的事情。总有一天，我们需要调整并接受其他人际关系可能会成为人们优先考虑的对象这一事实，尤其是如果这个新伴侣是他们正考虑与之生孩子、安定下来或结婚的人。随着我们步入二十岁，这种情况发生得越来越多，并不是想对此表现得铁石心肠，但你要么继续留在“彼得潘乐园”里，想着：“不，我想要单身、好玩、喝醉酒，一辈子都在一起”，然后看着其他所有人都超越了那个梦想、超越了那种现实版本；要么你就可以选择适应并与他们一同成长。然而，在这些情况下，我仍然觉得如果你感觉到对朋友的怨恨正在滋生，那是你需要拿出来谈谈的事情。你不需要非得说：“嘿，我嫉妒你的男朋友，因为他得到了你更多的关注，这太不公平了。”你可以委婉一点。我认为值得一提并这样说：
a lot of shame for, but it's just kind of the truth, right? Humans want more. We always want more. We always want what's best for us. We always want more love, more possessions, more affection. and sometimes I think seeing something that we value like our friend's affection and our friend's compassion and our friend's company get quote unquote taken away can lead us to feel very defensive. Unfortunately, I don't think that that is something we have control over and it is not something that we can voice. There will come a time when we need to adjust and accept that other relationships may be a priority for people, especially. if this new partner is someone that they're thinking about having kids with or settling down
“嘿，下次我们一起出去时，我们能单独相处一会儿吗？你知道，我真的很想你，我觉得我们没有机会好好叙叙旧。”邀请他们单独出去。表现得有些坚定，说明你需要只有你和他们的优质时间，或者有些事情你不想与陌生人（即他们的新男友或女朋友）分享。我认为一个好朋友是会听取这些意见的，他们不想看到你受伤、烦恼或难过。所以他们会听你说。他们会注意到你有什么心事，也许他们会解决这个问题，或者他们可能会猜到，然后他们会做出一些改变，意识到你们的关系虽然没有被危及，但已经被他们的新优先级所改变了，而他们必须决定是继续保持那个优先级列表，还是确保你感受到被关爱。再次说明，这并不是要你表达对他们伴侣的看法，也不是想在他们的恋爱决策上施加某种影响。这只是关于处理在你权限范围内的事情，也就是你们友谊的质量，以及你觉得为了维持这段关系，你和你们的关系需要什么。我认为尽管这些例子很艰难，但它们确实需要我们具备一点敏感度，并思考我们在这些情况下希望听到什么。我们都知道那种完全被某人迷住、神魂颠倒的感觉是什么样的，
with or getting married. That happens a lot more the further we get into our 20s and not to be like kind of tough love about it, but you can either stay in kind of Peter Panland and be like, no, I want to be single and fun and get drunk and be all together for the rest of our lives and watch everyone else outgrow that dream and outgrow that version of reality or you can kind of adapt and grow with them. In those situations, though, I do still feel like if you're, if you're sensing resentment coming up towards your friend, that is something you need to talk about. You don't necessarily need to say, hey, I'm jealous of your boyfriend because he gets more of your attention and that's so unfair. You can be delicate about it. I think it's worth addressing and saying,
我们戴上了眼罩，除了他们之外真的什么也看不见。这是一段美妙的时光。但它在某个阶段也会过去。你希望确保当它过去时，你的关系、你的友谊依然存在。所以我认为只需引起朋友的注意并说：“嘿，我只想单独见见你。我只想和你单独聊聊。”
hey, like, next time we hang out, can we just have one on one time? You know, I'm really missing you and I feel like we haven't had a chance to like fully, you know, catch up, ask them to hang out one-on-one. Be somewhat assertive that you need quality time that it is just you and them, or that there are things that you don't want to share with a stranger, i.e. their new boyfriend or girlfriend. I think a good friend is receptive to that and they don't want to see you hurt or bothered or upset. So they'll listen to you. They'll notice that there is something that is on your mind, perhaps they'll address it or they'll probably guess it and they'll make some change that your relationship is being not jeopardized but is being altered and changed by their new priorities and they have to
嘿，比如，下次我们一起出去玩时，我们可以只有我们两个人的时间吗？你知道的，我真的很想念你，我觉得我们还没有机会完全，你知道的，叙叙旧，要求单独出去玩。要表现得有点坚定，表明你需要高质量的相处时间，只有你和他们，或者有些事情你不想与陌生人分享，也就是他们的新男朋友或女朋友。我认为一个好朋友会接受这一点，他们不想看到你受伤、烦恼或沮丧。所以他们会听你倾诉。他们会注意到你有什么心事，也许他们会解决它，或者他们可能会猜到，并且他们会做出一些改变，即你们的关系并没有受到威胁，而是由于他们新的优先事项而受到干扰和改变，他们必须
decide whether they want to continue with that priority list or make sure that you feel cared for. Again, this isn't about you expressing an opinion about their partner or wanting to have some influence over their decision making when it comes to their relationship. this is just about addressing what is within your scope, which is the quality of your friendship and what you feel you need and your relationship needs in order to be sustained. I think although these examples are tough, they do require us to have a bit of sensitivity and think about what we would want to hear in these situations. We all know what it feels like to just be like totally enraptured with someone, totally head over heels.
决定是继续保持那个优先级列表，还是确保你感受到被关爱。再说一次，这并不是要你对他们的伴侣表达意见，也不是想对他们在处理感情时的决策施加影响。这只是关于处理在你职责范围内的事情，也就是你友谊的质量，以及为了维持下去你觉得你和你的关系所需要的东西。我认为虽然这些例子很难，但它们确实需要我们有一点敏感度，并思考我们在这些情况下想听到什么。我们都知道那种完全被某人迷住、神魂颠倒的感觉。
we have our blinders on, we really can't see anything but them. And it is like a wonderful time. It will also, at some stage, pass. And you want to make sure that your relationships, your friendships are still there when it does. So I think just catching your friend's attention and being like, hey, I would love to just like see you one on one. I would love to talk to you one on one.
我们戴着眼罩，除了他们真的什么也看不见。这是一段美好的时光。它在某个阶段也会过去。你想要确保当这一切过去时，你的关系、你的友谊依然存在。所以我想，只要引起你朋友的注意，然后说，嘿，我很想单独见见你。我很想跟你单独聊聊。
Can we do something that's like quality time? That's a really important first step. I think that if they respond to that positively, great. If they don't, that's a further discussion where you have to be like, then you can kind of pull out the card of like, never say you don't like their partner, but do say like, I don't like how our relationship or our friendship has developed since you started dating this person. I'm so happy for you, but I also think that what we have is important and will be around, has been around a lot longer than this other relationship.
我们可以花点时间享受高质量的相处吗？这是非常重要的第一步。我觉得如果他们对此反应积极，那就太好了。如果没有，那就需要进一步讨论，你可以打出这样一张牌：千万别说你讨厌他们的伴侣，但可以说：自从你开始和这个人交往以来，我不太喜欢我们之间的关系或友谊的发展方式。我为你感到高兴，但我也觉得我们之间的情谊很重要，而且会一直持续下去，它存在的时间比这段新恋情要长得多。
hopefully I want it to be around for the rest of our lives. So let's keep working on it. I do think, though, there are other instances in which we can see things that our friend maybe can't. And you do feel like you need to intervene. You rightfully should be saying something. This does happen. And we're going to talk about all of that and more after this short break. 2%.
我希望这份情谊能伴随我们一生。所以让我们继续维系它。不过，我觉得确实还有其他一些情况，在这些情况下，我们能看出一些问题，而我们的朋友可能看不出来。当你觉得有必要介入时。你理所当然应该说点什么。这种情况确实会发生。在这段简短的广告之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs. when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience
这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例。在旁边也有自动扶梯可选的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学，
that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
这些伪科学充斥着整个健康产业。我们曾坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2 PERCENT，可在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得 Diana Ross 在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍了两次小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在播客《Look Back at It》中找到答案。我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。每一集，我们都会精选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence.
大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白说，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊当年的可卡因，只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆上台面了。谢谢你帮我把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将结合自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross,
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却仍然在盲目追逐，我们不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们总是在盯着积分榜。生活变成了一场关于输赢的竞赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），
because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast,
因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要，还是你做一个好人只是因为你害怕？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地做一个好人。加入我和基尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话，
learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the hard way and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
《Learn the Hardway》。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckard）发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的自相矛盾之处。由此引发了一场长达数年的法律之战来证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through,
你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破获了这个案子。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个曾经历过……的男人，
the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues,
同样的遭遇。格雷格、莱斯皮安、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，
Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast
劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里icopa县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。收听《Love Trapped》播客，
on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。规则一，千万别惹乡下女孩。你玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也千万别惹她的朋友。我们总是说，要相信你的女朋友们。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends, Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《女朋友们》中，天啊，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个惯犯骗子。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这怎么可能发生在我身上。警察似乎根本不在乎。所以他们决定自己动手。我说，噢，见鬼不。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Toxic relationships in our 20s at any age, really, do exist. they are a disaster to watch from the outside. They are so painful, especially when we feel powerless to do anything, to help this person to change their situation. I think it's especially
我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到他应得的下场。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。我们二十多岁时的毒性恋爱——其实在任何年龄都一样——确实存在。从旁观者的角度来看，看着它们简直是一场灾难。它们是如此痛苦，尤其是当我们感到无能为力、无法做任何事情来帮助这个人改变现状时。我认为尤其
distressing when we see a friend falling into a situation we know is not good for them. And we really cannot intervene. And when we do attempt to intervene, it only serves to jeopardize. the connection that we have with that person and our relationship with them. As a friend, I think we kind of take on the role of guardian angel in a lot of circumstances. We are the ones who defend our friends when they can't. We are there for them when they need us most. We will be honest with them about what matters and supportive about the things that, you know, might look small to us. And whilst I have readily been recommending a silence is the best policy for situations, where you don't like your friend's partner,
令人痛心的是，当我们看到朋友陷入一段我们明知对他们有害的状况中时。而我们却真的无法干涉。当我们试图干涉时，它只会危及我们与那个人的联系以及我们之间的关系。作为一个朋友，我认为在很多情况下我们扮演着守护天使的角色。当朋友无能为力时，我们是为他们辩护的人。当他们最需要我们时，我们会陪伴在他们身边。我们会对他们坦诚什么才是重要的，并支持那些，你知道的，在我们看来可能微不足道的事情。虽然我一直毫不犹豫地建议对“不喜欢朋友伴侣”的情况采取沉默是金的政策，
I think that there are a series of scenarios where you have a duty to speak up and speak up quickly. Here are some examples of this. I think if your friend is dating someone who is overly controlling and tries to limit their contact with you or other important people in their life,
但我认为在某些情况下，你有责任大声说出来，而且要迅速说出来。以下是一些例子。我认为，如果你的朋友正在和一个控制欲过强、试图限制他们与你或他们生活中其他重要人物联系的人交往，
if they are dating someone who is physically, emotionally, mentally, verbally abusive, somebody who is enabling them and causing them to make decisions that you know are dangerous, someone who has lied to them about something, especially something important. And you know the truth, right? So if they are cheating on your friend or lying about something in their past and you know otherwise, I think that you really have a responsibility to say something.
如果他们正在与一个在身体、情感、精神、言语上虐待他们的人交往，一个纵容他们并导致他们做出你明知很危险的决定的人，一个在某事上对他们撒谎的人，特别是关于重要事情撒谎的人。而你知道真相，对吧？所以，如果他们在背叛你的朋友，或者在过去的某件事上撒谎而你知道实情，我认为你真的有责任说出来。
If this person is manipulating them financially, if they're displaying signs of extreme jealousy or possessiveness, I think essentially any kind of behaviours that are coercive, abusive, manipulative or exploitative, you have a duty to intervene. Even if just from like a wellness check perspective, making sure they are okay, that is the bare minimum. There is certainly so much more that you can do. And I want to talk you through this, but before then a quick caveat that there is so much advice to give, not all of it is going to match your situation. And there are so many other online resources for this and trusted individuals like a psychologist or a counselor or even a doctor or someone in law enforcement
如果这个人对他们在经济上进行操控，如果他们表现出极度嫉妒或占有欲的迹象，我认为基本上任何具有强迫性、虐待性、操控性或剥削性的行为，你都有责任进行干预。哪怕仅仅是从健康检查的角度出发，确保他们安然无恙，这也是最低限度的要求。当然，你还可以做更多的事情。我想带你了解这些，但在那之前先提个醒：有那么多的建议可以给出，并非所有建议都适用于你的情况。还有许多其他在线资源和值得信赖的个人，例如心理学家、辅导员，甚至是医生或执法人员，
that you should reach out to for more specialized, individualized help. I know that a lot of us know that, but sometimes I just want to make sure that, you know, if it is a really serious situation, you know where to go and you know that there are people out there to help you. But whilst you are trying to help your friend, there are some things that you can do. I think, firstly, create a space for open communication. You're not going to know or learn anything. Your friend is not going to address anything unless they feel like there is a space for them
你应该向他们寻求更专业、更具针对性的帮助。我知道我们很多人都懂这个道理，但有时我只是想确保，你知道的，如果这真的是一个非常严重的情况，你知道该去哪里寻求帮助，也知道外面有人可以帮助你。但是，当你在试图帮助你的朋友时，有一些事情你可以做。首先，我认为应该为开放式沟通创造一个空间。如果你不让朋友觉得有一个空间可以让他们
to talk and talk safely about it. So I would say be patient, invite them over to your place, keep the conversation light to begin with, ask them about their life, ask them about how everything's going. So it doesn't feel like an interrogation. They don't constantly feel like you want information about their relationship and you're trying to get them to leave, ask them questions that get them
畅所欲言、安全地谈论这件事，你是不会知道或了解到任何情况的，你的朋友也不会解决任何问题。所以我想说：要有耐心，邀请他们来你家，一开始让对话保持轻松，问问他们的生活，问问他们一切进展如何。这样就不会感觉像是在审讯。他们不会一直觉得你想要探听他们恋情的信息，并且在试图让他们分手。问一些能够引导他们
to reach the conclusion you've already reached on their own, because that will be more meaningful and effective if they recognize it themselves rather than having you tell them and feeling judged about it and feeling like they're getting all this information and then not quite sure it's correct because they haven't reached the same point and the same conclusion as, you have. You know, if your friend hasn't asked for help, you can't really expect to go into this conversation and just speak your mind unfiltered, right? Because they're going to be like, wait, what the heck? Where is this coming from? Like, my relationship is fine. My relationship is perfect. You know, there's a difference between wanting to help and passing judgment and statements like,
自己得出你早已得出的结论的问题，因为如果他们是自己意识到的，而不是由你告诉他们并让他们感到被评判，或者觉得自己被灌输了所有这些信息却又不确定是否正确（因为他们没有达到与你相同的点和结论），那么这种方式会更有意义、更有效。你知道，如果你的朋友没有寻求帮助，你真的不能指望毫无保留、直言不讳地开启这场对话，对吧？因为他们会想：等等，搞什么鬼？这从哪儿冒出来的？我的感情好得很。我的感情完美极了。要知道，想要帮忙和妄加评判是有区别的，像这样的言论：
he treats you so badly, or you just have to leave him. That is not going to help them articulate. how they feel and therefore get to that same point that you have. So when I'm talking about these questions that help them reach their own conclusion, this includes things like, do you think that's normal how they're acting? Or how do you feel about that? How do you feel about it when she does that? When he acts that way? Is that what you wanted in a relationship? Is that what you like in a relationship? All of these questions seem innocent enough, but I think if the person is unhavoured, and experiencing a difficult situation, it will reveal a lot. And it also keeps the focus on them and their feelings, not on your dislike for their partner, which I think can kind of make it
他对待你太差了，或者你必须离开他。这无助于他们清晰地表达自己的感受，从而无法达到与你相同的认知。所以，当我谈到那些帮助他们得出自己结论的问题时，其中包括诸如：你觉得他们的这种行为正常吗？或者你对此有什么感觉？当她做出那种举动时，你是什么感觉？当他表现出那种方式时呢？这就是你在恋爱中想要的吗？这就是你在感情中喜欢的吗？所有这些问题看起来都足够无辜，但我认为，如果当事人身陷其中，正在经历困境，它就会透露出很多信息。而且它还能把重点放在他们自己和他们的感受上，而不是放在你对他们伴侣的厌恶上，我认为这可能会让人觉得，
like, oh well, you know, they're only talking about this with me because they hate my boyfriend and they just want them gone. That's not what you're trying to do, right? You're trying to get them to open up. And if they are opening up, if they do, don't judge them. Like I said, before statements like, how could you not see this? How did it get this bad? What do you think was going to happen? You need to break up with him. I've known this since the beginning. Dump him. That firstly is like a very shallow way of seeing things that doesn't take in the complexity of the situation. But it also puts you on opposing teams when you want to be in the same corner and you want them to see you as an ally, not as someone they need to justify their choices to. Alongside that,
“哦，好吧，你知道的，他们之所以只跟我谈这个，是因为他们讨厌我的男友，他们只是想让他滚蛋。”这并不是你想做的事，对吧？你是想让他们敞开心扉。如果他们敞开心扉了，如果他们真的这么做了，不要评判他们。就像我刚才说的，像这样的言论：你怎么会看不出来？事情怎么会变得这么糟糕？你觉得接下来会发生什么？你需要和他分手。我从一开始就知道这一点。甩了他。这首先是一种非常肤浅的看法，没有考虑到情况的复杂性。但这也会把你们放在对立的阵营上，而你本想站在同一个阵营里，你希望他们把你视为盟友，而不是一个需要向其解释自己选择的对象。除此之外，
I also think don't try and force their hand by creating ultimatums or forcing them to really like have to come up with a plan straight away. Like I think that sense of urgency of like, what are you going to do about it? You have to break up with them right now. This is terrible. This is a disaster. I know that you're trying to do the right thing. I know that that's where you have the best intentions in mind to help guide them out of
我也认为，不要试图通过设定最后通牒或强迫他们立即想出一个计划来逼迫他们。我觉得那种紧迫感，比如：“你打算怎么处理这件事？你现在必须跟他分手。这太可怕了。这简直是一场灾难。”我知道你是想做正确的事。我知道你的初衷是最好的，是为了引导他们摆脱
what you see is a terrible situation. But I think that sense of urgency is going to set off. so much panic and alarm that if it was me, would probably result in a complete mental and emotional shutdown. They may have just realized that something was wrong. They may have just realized that what this behavior, this behavior they're experiencing is not right. They're going to need some time to adjust because they probably do love this person. You cannot go from loving someone to hating them in an instant just because your friend has said something, right? Like, it's a lot, it's a much more complicated journey than that.
在你看来糟糕透顶的处境。但我认为这种紧迫感会引发极大的恐慌和警惕，如果换作是我，可能会导致彻底的精神和情感崩溃。他们可能刚刚意识到出了问题。他们可能刚刚意识到他们正在经历的这种行为是不对的。他们需要一些时间来适应，因为他们很可能确实爱着这个人。你不能仅仅因为朋友说了一些话，就在一瞬间从爱一个人变成恨一个人，对吧？这需要一个复杂得多的过程。
It could be, take months. It could mean that they just need some more evidence to understand what is going on. And I think that that urgency created by forcing them to make a decision can create a lot of cognitive dissonance. They obviously value your opinion. They know how they want to be treated, but they also know that they love this person. and they believe that this person loves them back. So it's hard to square all of those different and contradictory beliefs into one small space, right?
这可能需要几个月的时间。这可能意味着他们需要更多的证据来理解到底发生了什么。我认为，通过强迫他们做出决定而制造的那种紧迫感，会产生大量的认知失调。他们显然很重视你的意见。他们知道自己希望被如何对待，但他们也知道自己爱这个人，并且相信这个人也爱他们。所以，要把所有这些不同且相互矛盾的信念放在一个小空间里去调和，是一件很难的事情，对吧？
It's hard to believe all those things at once. They're going to experience some mental discomfort while they work through that. And we want them to choose the two former beliefs, that your opinion is valuable and that they know how they want to be treated. We don't want them to choose the two former beliefs of like, oh, sorry, the two, two latter beliefs, latter, former, last beliefs of like, oh, this person loves me and this is normal. Also, I think it's important in these situations to have empathy for why people may accept what you don't think they deserve. It's really crucial to be aware of what keeps people in bad relationships. It's very easy for us to, you know, say that that's bad and say that they shouldn't tolerate that and
要同时相信所有这些事情是很困难的。当他们在克服这些心理障碍时，会经历一些心理不适。我们希望他们选择前两种信念，即你的意见很有价值、他们知道自己希望被如何对待。我们不希望他们选择——哦，抱歉，是最后两种信念，即：哦，这个人爱我，这很正常。另外，我认为在这些情况下，对人们为什么会接受那些你认为他们不配得到的对待抱有同理心是很重要的。了解是什么让人们留在糟糕的亲密关系中至关重要。我们很容易说这很糟糕，说他们不应该容忍这种事，
that's that, you know, there it is, the logic is sound. But you're not the one experiencing the attachment. You are not the one still reflecting on the good memories. You are not the one who sees this person's potential and has imagined a future. You are an outside party and we all know the feeling of giving someone advice. We know we could never take. Or knowing that something is easier said than done. People stay for a lot of reasons. They're scared of the unknown. This situation may not be great, but at least it's the devil that we know. We're fearful of what it could mean to be alone. There is so much uncertainty to a life without this other person, without the comfort of a partner. And although it is maybe a toxic relationship,
然后就这样，你知道的，逻辑很严密。但你不是经历这种依恋的那个人。你不是那个还在回味美好回忆的人。你不是那个看到了这个人的潜力并幻想了未来的人。你是一个局外人，我们都懂那种给别人提建议的感觉。我们知道有些建议我们自己也绝对做不到。或者知道“说起来容易做起来难”。人们留下来有很多原因。他们害怕未知。这种状况可能不太好，但至少是知根知底的恶魔。我们害怕孤独意味着什么。没有了另一个人，没有了伴侣带来的慰藉，生活将充满如此多的不确定性。尽管这可能是一段有毒的、
a negative relationship, at least it feels comfortable and familiar and leaving feels really scary. It may also come down to poor self-esteem. They might not think that they can do better. We all have our own sense of self-worth and our self-concept. And although you may be looking at your friend being like, literally you are the most beautiful, magnetic, intelligent, wonderful human to exist, they may not share that belief or see it from your outside perspective. I think also sometimes we are blind to the problems in our relationship because we need to be in order to survive. in order to, you know, from a place of self-preservation, you know, being able to recognize that things are wrong would mean that we would have to leave, which could jeopardize our safety,
消极的关系，但至少它让人感觉舒适和熟悉，而离开让人感到非常恐惧。这可能也归结于糟糕的自尊。他们可能觉得自己找不到更好的了。我们都有自己的自我价值感和自我概念。尽管你看着你的朋友可能会觉得：天哪，你简直是世上最美丽、最有吸引力、最聪明、最美妙的人，但他们可能并不认同这种看法，也无法从你这个局外人的角度来看待。我也认为，有时我们对感情中的问题视而不见，因为为了生存，我们必须这样做。为了出于自我保护的心理，能够意识到事情出了问题，就意味着我们必须离开，这可能会危及我们的安全，
which could put us in the place of a lot of doubt and fear. So it's easier to think that this is normal. It's easier to accept what is happening to us. There's also shame, a lack of resources, or the fact that what they're experiencing has become normalized. There is this theory in psychology actually called and learned helplessness that we've spoken about on the podcast before. And essentially, psychologists came up, but researchers discovered this idea when looking at experiments with dogs. And it was pretty nasty, but they would tie these dogs up and they would essentially abuse them. And they couldn't escape because they were restrained.
这可能会让我们陷入重重怀疑和恐惧之中。所以，认为这很正常会更容易。接受正在发生在我们身上的事情会更容易。其中还夹杂着羞耻感、资源匮乏，或者他们所经历的一切已经变得习以为常的事实。心理学上其实有一个理论叫“习得性无助”，我们以前在播客里聊过。基本上，心理学家们——也就是研究人员在观察针对狗的实验时发现了这个概念。这挺残忍的，他们把这些狗捆绑起来，基本上是对它们进行虐待。由于受到限制，它们无法逃脱。
They would then let the dogs go. And they would continue to abuse them. So even though the dogs weren't chained up, even though they really were free to go wherever they wanted, free to escape the pain, they stayed. Because they had normalized the experience and they had learned that they were helpless in changing anything. Sometimes these things are so ingrained they take time to dismantle. So you just have to be there for them. You have to be gentle, offer support, a shoulder to cry on, a place to be heard, and enlist the help of others they try.
然后他们放了这些狗。接着继续虐待它们。所以，尽管这些狗没有被链子拴着，尽管它们确实可以自由去任何想去的地方、自由逃离痛苦，但它们还是留了下来。因为它们已经对这种经历习以为常，并且学会了自己在改变任何事情上是无能为力的。有时这些东西根深蒂固，需要时间去瓦解。所以你只需要陪伴在他们身边。你必须温柔以待，提供支持、一个可以哭泣的肩膀、一个能够倾听他们心声的地方，并在他们尝试时争取其他人的帮助。
trust in love to get them to a point where they feel secure enough and safe enough and supported enough to do something, right? If they do make the decision, keep them focused on the future. How much better it is going to be, how much you love them and believe in them, how much they have waiting for them in the next few months that is going to be so beyond their wildest dreams, paint a picture for them and affirm their choices, affirm that this is the right. right decision, that they are making the right choice that you are proud of them. But don't lose hope if, you know, they go back a few times. Your job is not to force them into a decision they're not prepared for, but to love them and aid their decision, even if it's, you know, not the one that you
通过信任与爱，让他们到达一个感到足够安全、足够有支持感从而能够采取行动的地步，对吧？如果他们真的做出了决定，让他们把注意力集中在未来。事情将会变得多好，你有多爱他们、多相信他们，在接下来的几个月里，等待他们的将是多么超越他们最大胆想象的美好生活，为他们描绘一幅蓝图，并肯定他们的选择，肯定这是一个正确的决定，肯定他们正在做出正确的选择，你为他们感到骄傲。但如果他们反复几次，也千万不要失去希望。你的工作不是强迫他们做出尚未准备好的决定，而是去爱他们并协助他们的决定，哪怕这个决定并不是你会
would make. These situations are hard for everyone. I know that we started off talking about, like, just personally not liking somebody's partner, which is such a common experience, but it can get more extreme than that. And I know you feel a supreme sense of duty and you want to do something and you wish that you were in charge and you wish that you could make this change happen. But it's also not about you. I think in all of these examples, whether you dislike your friend's partner for arbitrary reasons, from a place of jealousy or from a place of genuine concern and safety, that is not about you. None of that is about you is about your friend. It is about what you feel they deserve, what they do deserve, the relationship that they have with you. And I think
做出的那个。这些情况对每个人来说都不容易。我知道我们一开始聊的是，纯粹个人不喜欢某人的伴侣，这是一种非常普遍的体验，但情况可能会变得更极端。我知道你有一种至高无上的责任感，你想做点什么，你希望自己能掌控一切，你希望自己能促成这种改变。但这也不是关于你。我认为在所有这些例子中，无论你是因为随意的理由、出于嫉妒，还是出于真正的关心和安全感而不喜欢朋友的伴侣，这都与你无关。这些统统与你无关，而是关于你的朋友。这关乎你觉得他们值得拥有什么，他们确实值得拥有什么，以及他们与你之间的关系。而且我认为
sometimes we can let our own ego get in the way and make us feel like we know best and make it feel like we could just do this all better and we should, they should just let us take the wheel and they don't know anything and they're making these mistakes and what were they thinking? It's not our journey. It's not our life. It's not our decision. So you just have to be there to support them and pick up the pieces at the end of the day because, you know, your friend will only listen and accept help when they are ready. And if you alienate them by judging them, by being like your partner is such a loser, they're annoying, they're awful, you know, like I said before, we know what it feels like to be in love. Whose side you think they're going to choose?
有时我们会让自己的小 ego（自我）挡道，让我们觉得自己最懂，让我们觉得自己可以把这一切做得更好，我们应该——他们就应该让我们来掌舵，而他们什么都不懂，正在犯这些错误，他们当时脑子里在想什么？这不是我们的旅程。这不是我们的人生。这不是我们的决定。所以你只需要在尘埃落定后，陪伴他们、支持他们，收拾残局，因为，你知道的，只有当你的朋友准备好了，他们才会倾听并接受帮助。如果你通过评判他们来把他们推远，比如“你的伴侣简直是个失败者，他们太烦人了、太糟糕了”，就像我刚才说的，我们都知道恋爱是什么滋味。你觉得他们会选择站在哪一边？
It's not rational. It is definitely not logical, but it's very human. to let ourselves be guided by emotion. So I hope that this episode has been of some help. I'm going to leave some resources in the description. I know that this kind of ended up being a really vulnerable and intense conversation, but I also hope that it helps because I know that a lot of us in our 20s are witnessing this or have experienced this where someone's just in that kind of relationship where you're like, do I need to say something?
这并不理性。绝对不符合逻辑，但任由情绪指引自己是非常人性化的。所以希望这一集能对大家有所帮助。我会在简介中留下一些资源。我知道这最后变成了一次非常脆弱且激烈的对话，但我也希望它能有所帮助，因为我知道我们二十多岁的人中有很多都在见证或经历过这种情况，当某人陷入那种关系中，你会想：我是不是该说点什么？
And it's hard to decide whether you do or whether you need to stay silent. So I hope that this has kind of guided you in that dilemma and in that experience. I've been there. I've done that. I've got the T-shirt. I have been both friends in this scenario. And, you know, there were things that I think I've said in the past to friends that I shouldn't have said that have tarnished our friendship. And there has been things that have said to me that have made me really isolate myself and not want to talk to those people.
而要决定自己是该说出来还是保持沉默，其实很难。所以希望这能指导你度过那种两难境地和那段经历。我经历过。我做过。我有过同样的体会。在这类情景中，两个朋友我都当过。而且，我想过去对朋友说过的一些话是不该说的，那些话损害了我们的友谊。也有人对我说过一些话，让我感到非常孤立，甚至不想和那些人说话。
So hopefully I've brought that experience to the table. You've taken something away from it. you've learned from it and if there is someone you think needs to hear this episode, please feel free to share it with them, share them a link, let them know that they're heard, let them hear this advice for themselves maybe. If you have an episode suggestion or if you just want to get engaged with the community, please follow along at that psychology podcast on Instagram. We would love to see you over there and make sure to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast,
所以希望我把这些经验带到了节目中。你从中学到了一些东西，并从中有所收获。如果你觉得有谁需要听听这一集，请随时分享给他们，发给他们一个链接，让他们知道自己被听见了，也许让他们亲自听听这个建议。如果你有节目建议，或者只是想与社群互动，请在 Instagram 上关注 That Psychology Podcast。我们很期待在那里看到你，并且请务必在 Apple Podcast、
Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. And make sure you're following along. We've got some really cool episodes coming out, some that are a little bit less serious than this. But once again, I'm wishing you love and luck. And we will be back next week with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs
Spotify 或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评。并且确保持续关注我们。我们接下来会推出一些非常酷的节目，有些会比这一集轻松一些。但再次祝愿大家充满爱与幸运。我们下周将带着另一期节目回归。《2%》。这就是走楼梯的人所占的比例，
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships. and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
在旁边也有自动扶梯可选的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、健身以及在这个奇特现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that
名字就是数字 2 PERCENT。可在 IHeartRadio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会的竟然是同一个惯犯骗子时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，
Trust your girlfriends Listen to the girlfriends Trust me babe On the Iheart radio app Apple Podcasts Or wherever you get your podcasts On the look back at it podcast For 1979
相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中关于1979年
That was a big moment for me 84 was big to me I'm Sam J And I'm Alex English Each episode We pick you here unpack what went down And try to make sense
那对我来说是个重大的时刻，84年对我也意义重大。我是 Sam J。还有我 Alex English。每一集，我们都会精选一个时刻，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解
Of how we survived it With our friends Fellow comedians And favorite authors Like Mark Lamont Hell, on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起，比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔，聊聊80年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。那是一个疯狂的年代。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间探讨的是黑人群体的男性经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在与一个懂行的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一身盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，你就必须去使用它，
listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
在 AHA 广播应用程序、Apple Podcast 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这段怀孕似乎是一个骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吧？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样遭遇的男人。
Greg Alespian and Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·兰日尼（Michael Ranjini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档 iHeart 播客。
Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
人工保证，本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。